hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt's ein eigentlich ich es jetzt
türkisches deutsch
jetzt bin ich verwirrt jedenfalls machen
wir heute die hand koren und wir machen
heute nicht den originalen flammkuchen
mit speck und zwiebeln denn wir zwar ist
er kein speck heute gibt es eine rallye
und murat variante und zwar mache ich
einmal den das grundrezept also den
flammkuchen teig und dann wird der
verschiedenen belegt für murat natürlich
mit ihr wird getürkt mit
und ich werde meinen mit putenbrust
belegen und wir zeigen auch noch eine
vegetarische alternative oder genau das
ist auch lecken lachs ist lecker also
man kann der flammkuchen wirklich auf
alle möglichen arten belegen alles was
man gerne mag einfach mit drauf
natürlich ist dann kein assist
flammkuchen mehr aber hauptsache es
schmeckt ja uns geht es aber schnell und
beim flammkuchen ist es so dass eine
teig ganz schön knusprig richtig lecker
aber auch freunde der im extranet
flammkuchen ofen im garten stehen dafür
schaut auch richtig cool ehre freuen
länger mehrere die stehen halt im sommer
draußen und dann kann man den schein
auspacken und ja im prinzip kann man den
teig natürlich auch fertig kaufen die
sind dann extra dünn aber ich finde das
genauso schnell selbst hergestellt und
für den franken gibt es keine jahreszeit
in köln das ganze jahr ganze jahr im
sommer oder auf dem weihnachtsmarkt oder
im herbst zum fehler weiter also ich
starte jetzt einfach mal mit dem
grundrezept also mit dem teig und dafür
braucht ihr nur ganz wenige zutaten für
den flug kuchenteig brauche ich 240
liter wasser und halben würfel hefe eine
prise zucker 410 gramm mehl 2 teelöffel
salz und drei esslöffel olivenöl jetzt
nämlich zuerst einmal das wasser
es kommt hier in einer schüssel ihr
könnt den teig mit den händen oder auch
mit der küchenmaschine verkneten
aber küchenmaschine geht natürlich
bisschen einfacher da kommt hefe und
zucker mit rein und ich löse cd film
wasser auf
jetzt gebe ich das mehl mit dazu und
salz und öl und dann wird der teig für
etwa sieben bis acht minuten seinem
geschmeidigen teig verknetet und hier
bei der cooking chef kann ich jetzt noch
die temperatur auf 40 grad einstellen da
geht der hefeteig nämlich gleichen
gewinnt werder auf der teig schön
geschmeidig genesis und wenn er fertig
ist dann klebte auch nicht mehr so
nämlich ein bisschen mehl auf die
arbeitsfläche und rollen zu einer kugel
zusammen
und den teig gebe ich jetzt zurück in
die schüssel und lassen für etwa eine
halbe stunde aufgehen
ich lasse den hefeteig geht es in der
kirche maschine auf gegen habe dafür
dass pro element weggenommen und kann
noch mal auf 40 grad einstellen ihr
könnt den teig auch abgedeckt einfach in
den warmen backofen stellen denen auch
einfach vorher auf 50 grad aufheizen
wieder ausschalten und dann kühlt darf
etwa 30 grad runter das dauert jetzt
ungefähr 30 minuten
der hefeteig ist jetzt aufgegangen und
ich habe ein paar zutaten gerichtet das
sind natürlich nur unsere vorschläge ihr
könnt ihr natürlich so belegen die ihr
möchtet vor allem könnt ihr so viel
belag nehmen wie er möchte deswegen kann
ich gar nicht so eine ganz genaue menge
angabe geben
also ich brauche ein paar
frühlingszwiebeln habe ich zwei normale
zwiebeln eine paprika champignons
cocktailtomaten hier sind getrocknete
tomaten in öl eingelegt etwas
hähnchenbrust ich hab ich noch
verschiedene käsesorten einmal den
tomaten käse also den turm kaffee käse
das ist so eine art gouda und ich habe
ich noch einen schnaps krise unter druck
und natürlich habe ich hier noch etwas
schmand assads 400 gramm und den schmand
wird sich jetzt mit salz und pfeffer ja
kein skript aufgewacht
jetzt stelle ich das kurz zur seite und
kann ich das ganze gemüse und auch das
fleisch erst mal klein schneiden
jetzt geht's an in flammen kuchenteig
dafür behle ich die arbeitsfläche ein
bisschen und der teig wird jetzt in vier
portionen eingeteilt und der muss jetzt
ganz dünn ausgerollt werden
und normalerweise würde ich das meinen
normalen aus hollstadt dafür benutzen
aber der legt noch im auto waren von der
messe gekommen sind also nämlich jetzt
den türkischen staat mit dem klub dass
er auch wunderbar
und wenn der teig dünn genug ist kommt
der auf dem backblech ich pack das jetzt
einmal hier auf meinem gelochten
backblech das drehe ich jetzt oben
dann habe ich nämlich sehr eine gerade
fläche und kriegt den flammen später
leichter runter es kommt jetzt darauf
dass auch richtig schön dünn geworden
oder ihr könnt es zum beispiel in diesen
krusty backformen backen diesen ja auch
gelacht und da wird der flammkuchen auch
sex spricht
und früher hat man den flammkuchen hier
einfach im ofen gebacken und im prinzip
war das eigentlich nur so ein ausnutzen
von oven also mal beim brotbacken den
ofen eben heiß gemacht und den
flammkuchen hat man da nur
reingeschmissen ja sozusagen um eben zu
gucken ob die der ofen schon heiß genug
ist oder aber noch zu kalt ist und dann
hat man den flammkuchen rhein gegeben
und wenn da jetzt so schnell dunkel
wurde war der ofen eben zu halten musste
eben noch warten
und wenn er noch nicht so schnell dunkel
wurde dann hat man den ofen eben noch
ein bisschen vermissen
jetzt kann ich die flammkuchen alle
belegen und bestreichen sanierer macht
davon übrigens noch eine kleine pizza
für sich
das glaub ich geb dir gleich ein
bisschen mehl und dahinten koch noch
eine suppe für die eltern also die küche
ist mal wieder ausgelastet
es gibt hier einfach ein bisschen von
der schwanz bremen auf die flammkuchen
drauf und ich verstreicht es mit einer
palette ganz dünn
jetzt gehts los mit dem belegen und zwar
mache ich jetzt hier zuerst einmal den
flammkuchen der für mich ist da kommt
jetzt ein bisschen putenbrust drauf
dann ein paar frühlingszwiebeln und ein
paar tomaten
und für die würze kommt noch ein
bisschen nomaden käse drauf und die
nehme ich schon brüssel ihn einfach
drüber jetzt kommt dass murat spezial
und zwar mit job und bei einem
flammkuchen es wichtig dass er nicht zu
voll geladen wird weil er der teig satin
ist und der flammkuchen express werden
soll
ein paar zwiebeln getrocknete tomaten
und ein bisschen paprika eine pizza
kriegt jetzt bisschen käse so reicht
oder und ich nehme jetzt auch für moritz
flammkuchen ein bisschen käse
und für die vegetarische variante nehmen
wir ein paar schattling jungs und
einfach ein bisschen gemüse und damit
ein bisschen würze reinkommt auch ein
bisschen turm käse und den letzten hier
mache ich noch laktosefrei da habe ich
laktosefreien schwanz drauf gegeben
bisschen pfeffer und salz und da kommt
als käse schafskäse drauf und einfach
noch die restlichen zutaten
die flammkuchen werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei etwa 240 grad
ober unterhitze für ungefähr zehn bis 15
minuten backen müssen einfach schauen
dass der teig schön kross ist aber dass
er ihm auch nicht verbrennt
jetzt sind die flammkuchen pferdchen der
murat darf probieren
ich habe jetzt bisschen abkühlen lassen
die spielt gerade mit zug oder alles
kann ich fragen darf studieren probieren
hat man sollte auf keinen fall auf den
bug blechen schneiden sondern immer auf
einem holzbrett also hier
man sieht es natürlich richtig dass
sieht rosberg sind es gar nicht nötig
sagt über zwischen echt toll aus und
leiht man eigentlich weiß geschmückt ich
mag den mit putenbrust so gern richtig
schön dünn und dadurch backen sehr sehr
knusprig und wie gesagt aus der menge
bekommt man vier flammkuchen raus und da
könnte er locker vier bis fünf bis sechs
personen mit ist also ich will es euch
empfehlen wir mal besuch bekommt besuch
zusammen ist zu machen wir hier zu
diesem raub hier sieht keine models
zeigen immer wieder auffrischen kolping
zaubern dann vielleicht sogar ihren
besuch zusammen belegen
es gibt ja richtig schnell hat man es
genau geht ruckzuck und viel viel
leckerer als sich für einen euro fünfzig
pizza reinzuschieben wirklich echt
klasse
ja und vor allem kann jeder drauf machen
was er möchte und es ist wirklich super
schnell gemacht und sehr einfach unsinn
wenige zutaten und glied nur und lachs
ja mit lachs im ausland decken also
vielleicht wollt ihr noch ein paar
andere variationen stehen das weiß mesum
basic grundrezept ich mag auch gerne
süßen flammkuchen zum beispiel mit
himbeeren und karamellisierten mandeln
oder mit birnen und äpfeln und zimt
zucker ist auch super lecker und falls
jetzt auch lust darauf bekommen habt
dann schaut auf sallis - block der eder
steht noch mal das rezept für euch und
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und wir sehen uns das nächste
mal wohl sein dass sie zu schauen
da habe ich ganz gut klappt gehören ist
echt super keinen fehler macht es nach
jeden tag
der hefeteig ist es aufgegangen und ich
kann jetzt schon mal die zutaten richten
ich habe ziele auswahl ich kann euch die
genaue menge gar nichts sagen denn ich
weiß nicht wie stark oder nächste aber
nur ein handy laut